damn i feel like we've probably seen
before
you both have actually yeah yes hey
how's it going
it's going well i
i was waiting on justice to say
something
i've seen you before and i also i think
didn't i just interrupt your interview
i wouldn't say you interrupted it i
would say that you came in to say hi to
a friend and it happened to be during my
interview
[Music]
well i apologize nonetheless
uh yes we uh all three of us have i've
spoken to each of you guys before but
moving past that so i have a lot of
questions but i have an individual
question for each of you first okay uh
for sydney i am curious what is it like
having white lotus air each week and the
amount of texts you get from friends
like asking please explain this to me i
need to know what's to happen uh
my response every single time is you
have to wait to the ending
it's incredible i mean the amount of
people who have just analyzed that show
to the degree that it has it's um
it's incredible scary at the same time
but
um
it's
rewarding in a sense
sure uh just my question for you is uh
i was a little nervous about this
dungeons and dragons movie but because
john and john are helming it i am way
more optimistic and believe this is
going to kick ass uh can you can you
just sort of talk about what it was like
being part of that project and
working with because both of those guys
are so talented
yeah yeah they're incredible they're
they're so funny and they have such a
clear vision
um i loved game night that movie is so
good
it's so good right it's so funny and and
everything it's just such a clear
specific story you know it doesn't try
to be anything that it's not and i think
uh they approach this the same way where
it's it's
i i can't spoil too much but it's you
know it's action-packed and it's
thrilling and it's funny as hell and
it's
um
it's it's all of the things and and yet
it it has a clear
uh
idea
you know uh i think like that
specificity is key in storytelling and
john and jonathan do that so well
um of just being like this is the story
we're telling you
but they're making it enjoyable the
entire time this is me not trying to
spoil the movie and any regards i've
given away no details
listen i i firmly believe it's going to
be something special just because of
their writing their ability behind the
camera but jumping into why i get to
talk to you guys today since making this
movie have you both found you are much
more careful about closing blinds and
being very cognizant about windows
yes
i i
am
i'm a little bit of an exhibitionist
so i open them all i don't mind
but i have been like
more more hesitant on social media and i
think that's like another
uh type of window looking of another
type of window into your life
um
yeah
no totally i think that this this film
while it's dealing with people
supposedly in the real world it's also
making a comment about
you know instagram and the fact that
we've all been it's our modern day
voyeurism yeah
hundred percent um and it's very
addictive it's just yeah that's a whole
nother thing but for each of you guys
what was it about the script and story
that said i i totally want to do this
there's so many aspects i mean
i
every
time i thought the script was done it
just kept going and there were more and
more that just happened and the choices
that pippa made
uh the writing was just it's it's so
smart and and keeps you on your feet or
your toes
you're on your feet
and and michael so i i loved working
with him before so being able to work
with him again was just
it's like a little family reunion
yeah and it's all it's just it's just so
sexy yeah this is so great
it makes you like feel a certain way
yeah it feels good
well what's interesting is that um this
is an erotic thriller and it's it would
and i've talked about those with michael
and others that it's weird that we are
in a place where you can get away with
doing the most violent stuff to people
in a movie totally fine but if you're
going to show sex or certain other
things it's like the you know the chains
come down you know what's crazy is
natasha and i were actually just talking
about this because they had a cgi to
make her underwear not a thong in the
trailer
really and we were like how is how is
having to turn her thong into
full-grown granny panties but being able
to see ben's entire bare chest and tidy
whitey's yeah okay like where
what is the line
yeah it's like i that's so cool that's
crazy yeah weird um
but yeah i think it's a i think it's
that's a really i think that's a really
good point like uh
violence is kind of
like built into our zeitgeist like even
like in children's cartoons like
violence yeah it's violent you know but
it's like but if you show yeah a thong
it's like that
is all about i'm trying to kill each
other
but like
but yeah if you show a thong like that's
that's bad when sex is just kind of like
an expression of connection and
and
it's purest form it's a love language
and
but violence is never a form of love you
know violence is never a form of
connection so
i don't know it's an interesting
discussion no it's f it's f'd up but so
if i'm not mistaken uh justice this was
your first time working with an intimacy
coordinator and i'm curious sydney if
you could talk a little bit about
popping his cherry
so listen i i just remembered in these
interviews that this was the first time
that i had an
intimacy coordinator and i worked
on an intimate scene like this
and but i wasn't sure but you just
confirmed because you've done your
research i used to i have done some
research
so this is the first time i've worked
with the internet no you know what i
have done an intimate scene before but
it was before intimacy coordinators were
thick that's sad i know
i just realized i'm sorry i did not know
i apologize
but you did say this is his first time
with an intimacy coordinator so you can
speak on that well he said
sid talk about that right isn't that
what you said
i would say that cindy should talk about
popping your cherry and um you should
i'm obviously joking and uh and but i am
curious what it's like because i think a
lot of people don't realize what it's
really like on set when you're filming
these kinds of scenes and the delicacy
that now takes place where in the past
that didn't exist
yeah i mean i think it's very important
to have someone there that's like in
your corner and making sure everyone is
comfortable and making sure that all
boundaries are respected
um
but
i
i i don't i don't like the word delicacy
because i i think it's like treating it
as if it's fragile and it's sensitive
where it might be but i feel like an
interesting coordinator is more
empowering empowering and technical yeah
and business oriented yeah like it's
like it's it's a business transaction
it's it's like you're there to work and
yeah like it's choreographed
yeah there's nothing dainty really
exactly yeah
i i want to i want to make sure that we
eradicate this idea that like when it
comes to intimate scenes everyone's
walking on eggshells and everyone does
there's literally a guy holding a boom
yeah it's like
it's like they're i think the beauty of
the intimacy coordinator is they take
all of that walking on eggshells away
and so it's like if you do feel
uncomfortable you can just pull them
aside and be like hey i don't know if i
really wanna or they can censor and they
kind of speak up for you without you
having to whereas before i i think
before it was more delicate because
before there was no one in your corner
and you just kind of had to go with the
flow of things and that's how a lot of
shitty [ __ ] shitty [ __ ]
shitty stuff happened
yeah no completely i mean when you
research hollywood you can hear horror
stories um yeah exactly
one of the things though about this film
and you sort of touched on it is that
the
this film takes uh how can i say this
delicately there's some big
twists and turns
that take place in this film that i was
not expecting and i'm curious for the
two of you what is it like reading a
script where all of a sudden
things
uh start happening if you will that you
might not see coming i called mike right
away really i couldn't believe it i was
like what is happening like this is
crazy
yeah i i signed onto the film after 40
pages because i just thought it was so
good i didn't even get to like the main
twists and turns but i was already so
captivated i was like this i have to be
a part of this
uh for both of you guys i love learning
about the behind the scenes like stuff
that you might not know um so i am
curious for both of you what do you
think might surprise people to learn
about the making of the film
who's surprisingly surprised people
filmed it backwards
we did film it backwards we filmed it
backwards because they had to um
they had to redress the entire apartment
both sides so we filmed the entire thing
backwards so yeah so the first couple
scenes was when the whole apartment was
already furnished and then we slowly
took things away yeah and so and then we
shot the first scene last where the
apartment was empty yep
i did not know that see this is what i'm
talking about
my last question for you guys uh it's an
individual for each of you um sydney you
have american soul coming up which i'm
very curious about and justice uh you
know i'm gonna ask about jurassic so um
for
what can you tease fans about that one
who's first wait me
even more
um jurassic you know
what can i is this that thing that we're
talking about where i don't can't say
anything yeah how much can i say um i'm
i'm back in the movie i am in it and uh
i still play franklin and he is uh
i will say there's an evolution to
franklin's character from jurassic world
2 to jurassic world 3.
um
and
that is what i will say but it's all
i'll also say there's dinosaurs in it
oh
spoiler
um i'm still in the midst of euphoria so
haven't been able to dive into anything
else but
yeah i i people might be excited for the
second season of that series it's
possible i hope so
cool um thank you for that uh wish you
guys nothing but the best thank you